et oui vous l'avez compris après plus de
1000 jours 1078 jours pour jean paul
kauffmann et du 230 jours pour marcel
fontani marcel carton on a effectivement
du mal à y croire je propose de revenir
quelques minutes sur le calvaire des
otages un calvaire qui a commencé le 22
mars 85
pour marcel fontaine et marcel carton
marcel carton qui vient d'être libéré et
est le chef du protocole à l'ambassade
de france à beyrouth
marcel fontaine était quant à lui vice
consul de france au liban
l'histoire d'une double prise d'otages
avec martine laroche joubert à vendredi
le 22 mars 1985 au matin on enlève à
beyrouth des diplomates français
le premier vice consul marcel fontaine
est poussé dans une voiture à 300 mètres
à peine de l'ambassade de france dans le
secteur musulman même heure près de la
ligne de démarcation toujours à l'ouest
le chef du protocole marcel carton et sa
fille subisse le même sort
elle est libérée fin mars pour les deux
otages l'engrenage
par cette lettre le djihad islamique
authentifie sa revendication et menaces
nous terroriseront la france les
familles des diplomates observe le
silence jusqu'à la première
manifestation organisée après
l'enlèvement de jean paul kauffmann
manifestation à laquelle y sont associés
de son côté dans l'ombre
la femme du diplomate marcel fontaine
effectué des marges sur démarches auprès
des religieux chiites
peine perdue premier contact avec les
otages
le docteur rade émissaire officieux du
gouvernement promet ses premières
lettres pour les familles et des
précisions les ravisseurs veulent un
rééquilibrage la politique française
dans le conflit iran irak et la
libération les derniers libanais détenus
en israël le 10 septembre 1985
ces prisonniers libanais du camp
d'athlètes sont libérés par les
autorités israéliennes
rien ne bouge chez les ravisseurs entre
temps les familles des otages sont mises
en présence dans le journal d'antenne 2
avec des représentants du mouvement
chiite amal libérateur des otages de
l'athée wrc pouvait les prendre sous son
aile et me promettent qu'ils vont être
libérés aussi ce soit le temps passe le
6 octobre 1986 le djihad islamique
envoie ses deux cassettes
et moralement que vous n'êtes plus
comment des images de troupes
je ne peux pas vous dire qui à la non
assistance à personne en danger
dix mois plus tard en août 96 nous
recevions cette cassette de marcel
carton
c'était ces dernières nouvelles avant sa
libération et celle de marcel fontaine